so here you are though are you excited
about this opportunity I am so excited
for Elias to continue sharing my life
with America but in a different way and
that's through dance it's so being very
vulnerable and sharing my story but it
doesn't have to involve a man right this
is all you and your partner of course
but it's it's definitely your talents
interstage they aren't you tired of
sharing your stories I'm scared I'm
talking about my dating life
yeah but know who I think I was put in
this position for some reason and I
think people need to see people with
this platform being really authentic and
real and showing realizations and I
don't have to be anything other than
that and so I'm okay with it if I'm
gonna be have these opportunities I
might as well use them to to share
something in common with the rest of the
world and people and that's just some
days being happy some days being sad and
having all been in between and making
people feel like that's okay to be right
and this fanbase loves to follow this
story as well as the dancing skills and
if they evolve
of course we followed a many of folks
from bachelor nation alum that have
participated in this show have you
reached out to any of them for advice
I've talked to a few of them about whom
well I have been a little bit busy but I
took a Nick Reese job the other day and
who reached out that I don't think was
bachelor nation that reached out the
other day had a lot of different people
I'd hoped in ginger from Good Morning
America but everybody has been just very
supportive but if the advice that
they're giving you be ready for it to be
Oh Bobby bones stop Bobby burns for it
to be very hard in some days to want to
quit but that'd be it's going to be the
best experience of your life so it's
kind of scary but also I'm really
excited just to like have fun with it so
I can have fun and have you know how to
have fun you love some sparkles and
rhinestones yo you got dance in your
background you're a former pageant girl
right yeah I'm gonna do today
yeah you have your eye on any of the
competition
Alabama hammerheads your competition
Hills my competition you think so I
think so in alley yeah yeah cuz she I
mean she's got she's got something I
mean yeah but it's okay I haven't showed
all my name's just yet
[Laughter]
you